oh god and then and then that's and then
that's the section this is the opening
for a gun oh no
one works
so once like the extent of what i know
ah
so i'll give you a few rules
so you should flip the board so you're
looking from black's perspective
yeah
if white ever plays z4 you instant take
it
okay one of the points of the sicilian
you want to trade
your less centralized c pawn for white's
center or d-pawn
so if white offers this trade you just
take it
and then you have two center pawns
against lights one center pawn
right of course white has a bit more
activity
um
but it's uh it's okay we'll you'll deal
with it
i'll show you maybe a more trappy
opening that can be effective
at uh
especially against the field
if anyone goes into this
i'll recommend starting with knight f6
back in the pawn
okay
a lot of newer players are just inclined
to trade where they'll take the knights
now question for you what you take back
with i take with the b-pawn good most
times you should take towards the center
this time especially take towards the
center you don't want to take and then
allow the queen trade
yeah
now
this will be a test for you pawn e5
uh it looks scary but you could just win
the pawn with um
queen to a5 queen a5 okay you've been
doing your puzzles good
yeah
285 is such a common tactic especially
in sicilian
right okay so if whatever takes and
plays
plays e5 you're you're happy
it's better for white to play
knight
c3
and then
the trickiest move i can recommend here
is pawn e6
i'm actually curious if maybe you would
play this anyway because you want to
develop your bishop
the point
is you want to exert as much pressure as
possible against e4 pawn
you're already attacking it once
you want to pin the knight
remove the defender and win e4
[Music]
a lot of the players will kind of play
kind of carefree here like develop their
bishop and go for castling if white
plays bishop e3
you develop your bishop and you pin the
knight you make a threat
yeah
white's already
[Music]
under some kind of uncomfortable
situation
white will have to defend the pawn if
they play a3 you take
you in the pawn you're happy
yeah
white will either play f3 or bishop d3
here
against either move you're going to play
d5 which is a really strong continuation
let's say bishop d3
you play d5
and your pieces are working like really
really nicely your knights control all
the center squares
you're maximizing pressure against e4
you're pinning this knight
you're threatening to win the pawn
if white takes
you take back with a knight
hitting this and this you're happy
bishop d2 trying to defend everything
you win the knight in d4
right yeah
so if white really tries to hold on
maybe they would play a move like f3
holding on for dear life
and then there's a
a fun move
on e5 just expanding
where now you're getting kind of the
ideal center and you're making a threat
in the process you're attacking the
um if night retreats
you just keep pushing and now you're
winning material yeah
so yeah it's uh it's exciting if you can
win like
just get a winning position really early
as black
if white takes
you're not winning material but you're
getting a really nice center still
pressure still threatening a fork right
still pinned so this is a
position a lot of players will stumble
into and the moves are very natural for
black with pawn e6 bishop e4
maximizing pressure and going for uh
just a
simple control of the the center
i don't want to overwhelm you with like
too many different opening variations
but i think this is a good starting
point
and if you do run into
like maybe some weird move you haven't
seen before you just kind of
ask yourself the questions like what
does opponent want to do
before you make a move make sure you're
you're not like giving away anything for
free
and as long as you got out of the
opening okay
um
and you i think the the middle game and
end game as we noted is your strongest
point
yay